hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen I was
filming today that I had to wear wigs so
I didn't want to take it off because
underneath this wig is just sweaty
tangled gross today I am watching Super
Mario Bros I don't know anything about
this film other than it's bad I grew up
playing Super Mario Brothers Super Smash
Brothers is my favorite game of all time
Mario Party 3 was a great game I know
the world I know the characters I hope
that they really use that in in the
movie I have a feeling they won't
because it's bad so if they did it
wouldn't be bad alright y'all first one
back after Tam tober fest let's get into
it
[Music]
what the oh so quick question did they
um I don't know utilize any of the fun
world that Mario brings in the video
games did they do they didn't they
didn't explore any of it why is this
made why you watched it with me did you
like it no I feel like I should have
laughed once this is never gonna be like
an oscar-winning film this is never
gonna be a movie that like breaks
boundaries and is like incredible but it
should be fun the thing is too is that
the acting wasn't terrible
like I felt like in Howard the Duck i I
didn't like the acting I thought that it
was really stupid I thought that they
weren't giving it their all and even if
they were maybe the scripts didn't lend
itself to that this I mean the scripts
definitely didn't lend itself to the
actors but I still felt like the acting
was pretty okay I bought what they were
saying I just didn't care at all your
villain sucks Cooper Cooper Cooper's
like the most boring character in the
series anyways in Mario's land anyway so
like okay such weird choices too like
this was before Daisy was a part of the
Mario world
Mario Party 3 I think Daisy was
introduced then but she wasn't around
when this was being like spoken about
this movie so like where did Daisy come
from and and and where was peach but
that's the whole thing when you make a
film based on nostalgic characters you
should make the film about miss the the
nostalgia
yeah okay you know it's it's already
done so it starts off and this blonde
woman delivers an egg to Upchurch and
this nun sees the egg and she takes it
in and and egg hatches and it's a human
child and the nun is pretty okay with it
surprisingly the nun is on board guys
say I wouldn't be as open-minded I hope
and you see Mario and Luigi they never
hit a mark where I was like I am into
these characters I'm invested I care
about them oh yes good great excellent
Wow
yes so Daisy is this archaeologist she's
looking at dinosaur bones that they've
found and it's interesting the work of
this businessman his name is scapelli
and he starts throwing out all these
threats to Daisy and it's really gross
like it's it's a gross tone for like the
beginning of the movie from just this
disgusting
crispy old man to be like I would watch
myself if I was you a lot of girls have
been going missing recently go get
another spray tan you hot dog with a wig
literally wearing a wig right now so
maybe I maybe I shouldn't talk but he
was gross then there's this weird moment
where Luigi's like yeah Mario's my
brother and my dad and my uncle and then
they move on and it's like no no no no
we need to address this is he your
father or your brother because I cannot
tell also Mario is dating a gorgeous
woman so good for him I don't see why
she is
dating him but I mean they don't really
dig deep into these characters so I'm
sure I'm missing something
maybe he is excellent in the sack jay-z
gets captured by Koopas like obvious
alien goons Luigi and Mario follow her
using terrible CGI and they're there and
Cooper Kate and it's so dumb it looks so
dumb and misguided and confused it kind
of looks like a mix between the future
in Back to the Future and then Blade
Runner it also looks like they had a
very limited amount of room to film on
like the set was like a couple like
sound stages I will say though I'm
always down for a plus-sized woman in
rocket boots
so then you meet toad for like 2.5
seconds so that's cool that they really
utilize that character I'm a lot of
questions about the whole movie as a
whole and just like very many individual
points but the most concerning I think
is that Mario's last name is Mario and I
don't like it I don't like it one bit
it's not funny it would be great if it
was funny but it's stupid as yeah my
last name's Mario
well my first name is Mario so Mario
Mario that's what you're going with
I'll give you a second that's oh okay
but the de-evolution scene of Toad is
kind of terrible I didn't have enough
time to really love toad because he was
on screen for two seconds but uh seeing
that process of him turning into a
Goomba was I will say horrifying
you know what I love about mud it's
dirty and clean
same time that's cool that's cool very
nice you know what I love about this
movie absolutely nothing but y'all Yoshi
is cute as hell Oh trust the fungus
which is apparently Daisy's father who
in the end is turned back into a king
[Music]
then at the very end she comes back into
the real world then Luigi is like Daisy
and she's like Luigi I need your help
you'll never guess what happened and
then she pulls up a gun it's a little
badass but it's like also I don't care
also I mean it's a movie that's like who
asked for this why do we need this film
we did it so if you're gonna make it
like at least make it fun and like super
into the world
you'll be pissed that video game movies
were probably stigmatized by this crap
totally video game movies already have
such a bad rap because they do there are
a lot of stinkers there are some that
still have like such a bad rating and
are like oh those are so bad but are way
better and more true to the characters
than this garbage i love lara croft and
tomb raider and I think those movies are
really fun I liked them a lot and I know
they're not good movies I know this I
understand
but at least it's true - like the video
games the only time you'll like the main
female character is at the end with her
big gun I did like the end with the big
gun I also loved the bouncer character a
lot of people are telling me to trust
the fungus I trust nothing about this
film uh somebody in the comments just
said that it's a live-action thrill ride
and let me tell you I do not agree oh no
people like people like this a movie
you're going to love the scene where
they give their full names at the police
station I think I'm gonna put this out
and everyone's gonna be like camera you
need to calm down you're being way too
harsh on this film I didn't enjoy it not
even fun it wasn't even fun you were
wondering why they're not hitting bricks
with their heads and collecting coins
that is something I'm gonna under there
I wish they would have done more with
the world that they were given this is a
movie that never needed to be made but
if you're going to to make a movie on
like a thing that already has a
backstory and characters and things that
happen it's so weird to me who okayed
this script well I feel like I should
keep this garbage train going with some
kids
we live in in garbage pails hopefully
you liked this movie I don't know it
seems like a lot of people like it in
the predictions which cool man
like like what you're gonna like that's
sweet
I did not okay see you next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you